so the question is like where i'm at
so
[Music]
yeah i moved from california
which i lived for 10 years to
amsterdam
in august
2021
and over the last four months i've been
working here with spentino massaro and
the team
and on our mission which is igniting
global awakening
and specifically training free agents
for the ignition of global awakening
and
it's been really clear the last couple
of months especially sort of just the
shift from
coming from a more conceptual place um
to coming from a more embodied place
so rather than having
emptiness be like a concept
rather now it's actually something
that's directly felt in the gut in the
heart
it's more visceral so emptiness of
self-interest
so coming from a pure place of wholeness
of wanting to serve life awakening to
itself
so that's been the primary thing that's
been reflected to me by ventino and the
team
um and it's been really nice
and at in the same time we're also
as we are buddhists we're also vikings
so at the same time we're
we've
created an incredible meditation mastery
program
that is
already influenced sixteen hundred
people around the world and is about to
get out to two hundred thousand people
by october twenty twenty two
um
we have no limit society which is going
really really well um
this is where
you have a direct access to the most
exclusive ongoing training
um which
is like no other on the planet um
and our like core team of people that
are
you know building this out are uh
expanding and we're manifesting sort of
the next level which is like no limits
nation itself
so meaning as we see like the matrix net
that's
tightening
we are
architecting
the next
shambhala
we could say so a place of pure freedom
a place of pure enlightenment a place
that is
the collective is seeking
that has decentralization
cryptocurrencies dows nfts
clean energy regenerative
ag
basic needs are met with water food
shelter
air
so
this is the type of
of
shambhalas that we can envision no
limits nations across the planet
so we're in the process of purifying
where we're coming from so purifying our
consciousness and the way it expresses
itself rather than going into
uh the conceptual territories which many
of us in the limits have already done
we've all already you know played with
god and source and infinity and
nothingness
all these types of things but now it's
well even though you know those things
intellectually
and you can say that you're
awake or enlightened intellectually
do you actually experientially
viscerally in your heart and gut do you
truly come from a place that is empty of
self-interest do you truly
feel the one talking to itself and do
you truly serve
um life awakening to itself in a pure
way and we can detect that once you've
sort of seen the patterns of
consciousness and how it expresses
itself you can very easily detect when
people are coming from a pure place
versus when they're coming from a place
that is
still unworthy and seeking validation or
has some sort of hidden agenda or
self-interest or that type of thing
so that would be the big update yeah on
my on my end
can you give me an example in which
recently
you have
felt
and experienced
serving life to awaken to itself
yeah
so
for example
what bentino and honorag have been
sharing the last two weeks is
to do a cleanup and
this is to
polish
the mud off the diamond uh this is to
unblock the chakras this is to
empty out that self-interest
and what we're doing is we're doing a
clean up of five specific areas first is
your physical space your digital space
then your relationships
the general administration of life
health and fitness
and your state of being
and
for example
this process is the best way to serve
life awakening to itself by turning
inward and doing the cleanup doing the
work
that's actually how
we
most efficiently serve life awakening to
itself
so
for example with me
uh
i just interviewed onoraga on the show
a couple days ago
and
it was awesome because he
made it
so simple that if you basically fall in
love with doing the work if you fall in
love with cleanup
if you participate in the
doing what you know you should be doing
club every single day
you will feel more and more alive and
awake and pure
and honorable every moment of existence
and so
for me i just
became more and more in love with the
cleanup and so like especially like this
last week i've just been like so in love
with doing
items on the cleanup and it feels so
liberating so for example
um i had a scenario like
maybe
six years ago or so
ish
um
where
uh i placed
another one of my friends into danger
and i
had not healed that
and so what i did is a couple days ago i
called them
and from a deep place of heart to heart
just opened up sending them so much love
sending them so much light and they are
very receptive because they themselves
are also waking up life is all waking up
and so
so i sent them some money as well and i
just felt so good about it and they felt
so good about it because they felt like
they were you know being loved and cared
for by something that wasn't healed you
know this they knew also that this
wasn't healed from six years ago yet
and so
so i willed
i chose
as the creator to heal that relationship
and to
bring the two
individuals more in to pure love with
each other rather than having that that
that distortion still between them
and
so
i he by healing that distortion in the
you could say network theory of the one
it
actually created the blossoming of pure
love of divinity and
yeah and so i've basically been doing
things like that
daily and it's been so good
yeah
wow yeah
are you are you engaged in other
projects other than the
no limit society
uh no limit nation and
the community
or yeah of course living there yeah yeah
i mean of course like simulation which
is our our channel um i still focus on i
also still focus on um synthesizing and
distilling the the essence of the nature
of reality through books through art
um
and
that's all one i found most recently
like in the last four months that
initially i had a conversation with
corey katuna before i came in the summer
and
it was about sort of like wondering well
how how is this how is this all going to
come together like
like the
the fact that i'm also
producing this show and i'm also
writing a lot and
and then just
taking so much of my time and energy and
efforts and putting them into no limits
and that um
her advice was to to surrender to the
highest timeline in the best case
scenario where it's totally non-linear
and everything merges into one and
anything that's not needed falls in the
in the wake
um behind
and
uh it was great because i came here and
i took a big break from posting anything
for a long time um i still haven't
posted anything really onto instagram um
and i've posted barely anything onto
youtube
and
then it feels really good because i've
been able to turn inward and hone in on
purifying where i'm coming from and also
serving the mission uh for what's being
shepherded here and then now most
recently those worlds are merging more
and more cohesively into into one so
yeah and and in general everything that
i've done in the past regarding like
working with scientists on
clean energy infrastructures or
understanding the nature of uh
of biology and um especially like
biotechnology and neurotechnology and
um
and all these different fields
um
it's all being basically integrated into
what we're doing with no limits nation
and so um i have no sort of
fear
with oh no
everything that i know about
how cells develop pathology and how to
prevent that so that we can have
longevity is going away because i'm not
focusing on i have no worry about that
at all because i know that everything
that i know about
longevity
is actually going to be implemented at
the exact right time
with the exact right network of
scientists that i've already established
connections with
as we manifest no limits nation which is
already
done it's already done so i also live in
a perpetual state of the enlightened
civilization that we all seek already
being done i live in a state where
shambhala is already across the world
and that's also really helpful
so i also live in a state where like
this call
is also already done and it's also both
of us have a big high five and a big hug
for each other and a big love for each
other because it went so well and
because we were able to
sync up communicate well and then
hopefully you know if we do decide to
distribute this that we it then makes
positive catalysts for people
so
yes love
i also am excited to ask you more so let
me know when you want to turn the new
tables
thank you
i'm really
feeling you when you're not talking
i'm feeling the change in you
since august
i feel a softening
trusting
i feel not knowing
so nice
yeah
yes softening trusting and not knowing
and yet being completely
immersed in this
cleanup and creation
that's happening at the same time
so as we're cleaning more creative
energy as we're
i'm feeling it it's wonderful
nice yeah softening and unwinding are a
really good way to put it because what
we're doing is we're taking what was
like energetic contractions
or
condensations of energy and we're we're
liberating them we're unwinding them
we're deconditioning our deconditioning
ourselves from separation and from
location and from
all of our lack beliefs of unworthiness
and needing to be validated and all
these things and so
it is a perpetual cleanup it's a
perpetual purification process
because being in love with that is
basically being in love with
the soccer game
like when we're talking to onorak he's
just making things so simple it's like
it's just a soccer game like
are you gonna like whine and complain
and try and be selfish with the ball or
are you playing on behalf of the hole
are you playing on behalf of the team
and do you train to play on behalf of
the team like you want to be an olympic
athlete in consciousness but you don't
want to train it's not going to happen
you have to train and that's the
purification that's the clean cleanup
[Music]
nice
yeah
so fun such nice little analogies and
like the skiing one that he was
mentioning was really good too like
the
the more that you practice skiing you
look for harder and harder hills and
that's the more and more difficult
levels of consciousness expressing
itself and purifying itself
yeah and
the same thing with the violin or with
basketball or with you know when you
first started learning how to ride a
bike or when you first started learning
how to read you know you had to learn
the alphabet and then
over time you learned how to read words
and they were easier words at first in
the medium level words and then hard
words and now you read really fast and
you type really fast and you can
articulate yourself really well and so
it's the same thing with consciousness
it's the same thing with the way you
express yourself is just doing the work
is like the fundamental abcs the
alphabet so that you can basically be a
ninja you can be a jedi you can be
magical be a wizard
at being able to detect these
distorted patterns of consciousness and
when people seek
freedom when they seek purification
liberation you can actually serve
your other self
beautiful
nice
nice
[Music]
for sure a lot softer yeah
it's a lot warmer
feels like a lot more of like the divine
love is just present and radiating
that's a lot less conceptual
for sure
thank you yes sweetheart
only within three months wow
yeah it's a big that's a big testament
to what um is capable not only um
for humans but also what this field
actually
uh represents because it basically
represents this you could say that what
you've seen as a transformation in me
from
august until november
is
what this field represents you know it
represents that and so if if you really
seek
liberation freedom
um purity and service to others
um
getting involved with this field is your
you know your most accelerated path
yeah
it's so good
thank you
cool
can we shift the tables is a good timing
for that
yeah okay beautiful
so
every time that i tune in to you
i basically see
a
a version of what
i'm
super passionate about
and doing it in a way that i
haven't really done it or like seen it
yet
and so that's i think what really
gravitates me
uh to you
is like everything that you've done with
installment
has been
for me
is basically like the visualization
of
the distillation of the nature
and
that is so cool to me and
that's what excites me about our
relationship is how much you've how much
groundwork you've already done there
and now for me
um it's exciting because i'm i'm
[Music]
i see a future where we
are able to integrate
insolvent with what we're doing here
and
just make it even more rich even more
simple even more relatable for like the
mainstream
and then package it in ways that is
accessible for the mainstream
and then
to help
actually get it out and to serve what
people are actually seeking so to
fulfill that that need
um how does that resonate
wow
hmm
there is there is a
there is a
an impulse inside me
that
is um
it's so interesting okay
so
right now you and i are in the now our
now we're in the now
and
there's a future
there is what has been creation created
the distillation of this nature of
reality
which is just like like a beginning
point
so there's a future
so-called future because uh we use
language but there's a future state
like you said it's already done so
there's a future
that's
that's like
dancing
playing
pushing itself
there is something that has been created
and now there's this now
so within me there's an impulse
that i cannot quite articulate i could
but i not really
the same way
you know you can't quite articulate
being
it's just the experience of being
anything you could try to articulate is
is a is a lower grade quality of being
so
there is an there is a movement in me i
don't know a movement or pull or or or
that is that has to do with
um
creating a field
distinguishing a field not creating
distinguishing a field in our
consciousness
it has to do with reality exploration
or reality
principles or reality processes
fundamentals particles of reality
so there's this
um
something that's much greater than than
i am much greater than us
okay because it's really at the source
of consciousness of the source of being
at the source of awakening
so there's this part of me
this this part of this movement this
this
uh
yeah i think it is a movement it is a
movement and it's like this
it's coming through like this
um
yes
cannot quite be articulated
but there's something that won't be
birthed it's almost like
when you had the hunters and gatherers
and you would talk to them about crypto
that's coming up in a they're like
okay something like this
because it's coming from the future
though
it's our future so we own it and we are
that
so we could we could
connect with it so i'm answering this
because when you mentioned about
the the process i went through with the
distillation of installment
the nature of reality and how it could
dance with
combined with play with
no limits and the simulation project and
other projects
i really like it i like it a lot
and
yeah i love it i love it and
it is it is something that is greater
than what we can articulate that's
number one number two it has to do with
us with consciousness or us
truly
[Music]
embodying and aligning with the nature
of reality
and consciousness is included in the
nature of reality
energy is included healing is included
frequency is included relationship are
included it's almost what are the
fundamental
principles and operating
uh
paradigms that are working us and we are
as we're inventing them they are working
us
so there's something about we inventing
and we creating and and then we we get
swept swept right in them so there's
something really important about that
about really understanding the code the
very very very very basic code it's way
beyond the dna because it does it it's
at the level of essence
okay it's at the level of being it's at
the level of becoming
and this this
creating like a reality
explorer
you you call it like you know no limit
society or the no limit nation or the
the work
that that different communities are
doing and i'm interested
because also no limit society is also a
manifestation a very high grade
manifestation of refined consciousness
in action and in relations and in that
but there's something underneath it as
well underneath mean that it's actually
it's at its essence at its ground
now why is it important
to to even bring that
to life to expose it to not even expose
but to reveal it to to explore it and
reveal it
because when we really understand and
align ourselves with these universal
principles
that are essential in nature
then we can really create heaven on
earth not only in one
no limit society or one country or one
person or one
but
it's like an operating system that takes
over like the internet
uh that
just
we created that reality it's almost
creating
a nature of reality reality within our
reality
and when we create it
and we understand how in real time oops
look look look
like in real time your way to the code
being coded and you're embodying it
then we can actually start creating
realities that are way way
i wouldn't even use the word
enlightenment it's way more than
enlightenment it's like we really become
a vessel
a
transmitter
a broadcaster of
reality that's aligned with universal
laws now i'm saying all this
absolutely installment plus no limits
plus simulation is very exciting
and what i'm doing on in in other one of
my other projects
is actually starting to look at it
you know how uh toe
you know the theory of everything i
think you interviewed him uh yeah kurt
yes
you know wonderful work wonderful in
depth
so imagine imagine
because see not only these interviews
are informing
the nature of reality but every
experience that arises ah reality
reality everything is like you have here
masses of
data telling us about
reality
and we're not quite reading it
decoding it or at least guiding it
guiding our evolution with the
principles of it
so
so what i'm curious about is
how could we create a mechanism
that of course includes technology and
includes all the the crypto nft dolls
regenerative societies how do we create
a mechanism
that will allow reality to become
transparent to us
nice
yeah so good
and i don't know yet because and this is
why i'm telling you it's coming from the
future meaning
it's not like you know in the old days i
mean you know i used to be
used to be in business and i used to i
used to be a like information architect
architect so
it's like in in this type of
organizations you have a goal you have a
vision
this is what we're doing two to two you
march toward these goals but there's
there's a whole another way that's
wanting to birth itself
um
of reality to become transparent to
the creator itself
each one of us is a creator each one of
us like every gem every plant every ant
it's not only us we think we're like wow
but
we're not we're really really really not
uh we're just able to talk about it and
do a big deal out of it but actually
everything is doing it all the time
everything is creating realities all the
time
the ocean the earth the plants
the clouds i was just thinking about the
service of the rain because
it had it hasn't rained here
and i was like does do the cloud
really do things in service of the earth
i mean how
like what's
what's really in the mind so today i sat
for two hours we're looking at the cloud
i'll send you photos after
um
and i was looking at the cloud and i
said
do these do these clouds
do this cloud talk about
do they talk about
service of the earth like what's up with
them what are they doing what's their
consciousness okay
what's their um
like
because because reality is not excluded
only to us reality is everywhere so i'm
interested in the operating system of
reality and how could we actually bring
people together or i don't know if it's
people maybe it's a completely
distributed autonomous
you know dow reality dao
that generates wisdom
like you generating right now at the no
limit to society like installment is
just one manifestation of intelligence
it's nothing more than this
you know how do you take old and let's
say kurt's
2000 interviews that he had
how do we take that
bring them together
to generate so they can talk with each
other not humans but these these
intelligent
wisdom like what you're doing right now
with the cleanup and all this the
physical digital relational cleanup all
this is intelligence how do we take all
this
and then allow them to talk
nobody owns that it's reality who owns
it okay
and then there's another level of
intelligence then wisdom then insight
then complete pure
pure awakening that has no words so how
do we do that in a way that's really
reflected back to us at any moment
that's what i'm i'm thinking i'm
playing with right now
so installment two is going to be
published uh by the end of this year
uh and this is this is what i'm doing
right now i'm kind of and this is why i
you are very an attractive
and attractive young man
uh to reality
to me too but to reality let's talk
about that
and
this is why it's like hey what's up with
atlas what is and then i saw your
interview i told you about you and the
other lady and i was like yeah good
stuff
and that's why
that's how we we connected again
i know we've been together i mean i
could feel you and you could feel me
um
but it's like what who are the
the founding members of this
this
organism
i don't know
yeah nice there's so many good threads
there um one that you brought up earlier
that i feel like we can play on
is
that
the focus on the state of being
is what
enables
the
architectures to be pure
and also to be
focused on things like the seventh
generation principle like in indigeneity
where everything that we're building is
300 years plus
focus in the future rather than the
short-term
gratification of now for self-interest
so
when the state of being
empties out of self-interest and the
state of being becomes more
in pure service to life it's
it's a no-brainer to
give
all self-interest away and to relinquish
that
called karma yoga etc
where
you're not interested in immediate foods
but rather you care about serving life's
most
best case highest trajectory scenario
and that includes all the different tech
stacks that we were talking about
and it includes the synthesis of all of
the incredible distillations that we're
already manifesting
so it's from the state of being and then
like you said then there's this
another thread
is there's this operating system for
reality
so there's kind of like the
there's like it's like a taurus
and um what arises and passes in that
parietal field
and
that
the arising seems to be some sort of a
let's say
um some sort of like a zero point energy
that then gives rise electromagnetically
which you could say is love and light
to awareness
which then
is some sort of a
a confluence
or a conglomeration of things like
sensation and experience
and then that sensation and experience
in awareness that is made of love light
will like a taurus
as the arising occurs
then the passing also occurs
and the dissolving right back into the
same zero point energy that gave rise to
it
um
and so that seems to be like what the os
is in one extent or one layer and then
another layer you could say it's that
like the universe
itself
is a mechanism
that intelligent infinity
uses
two
actualize
pure potentiality
so pure potentiality is actualized
via
universes and conscious agents
right
yeah so i would say that i would say
that those are like the two components
of the reality os like the macro and
then the micro like sensational
experiential
um
and
so let's let's combine that into some
sort of a you know
like vr pedagogy for kids um and then
just get them
uh
meeting their basic needs and getting
them um to know the true nature to like
you said make reality transparent to
itself and then
um
that's really the birthing of this sort
of fourth density
earth
um that is saturated with love light
enlightenment
um
meeting all basic needs maximizing
everybody's actualization of their gifts
um
yeah
and so so that's that's really exciting
like social memory complex it's it's
really exciting and
um and and i i also love how you say
like there's something that's coming
through that it's already done
but that
you're just like me
and you're like continuo and honorable
in our team here and so many of the
visionaries around the planet which are
basically saying the same thing which is
that that is coming through you could
call it like the human singularity chris
langen also
and he's his work is amazing as well and
understanding the nature of reality as
well as also especially with
like meta religion is really cool it's
basically
what's his name uh christopher langan
yeah yeah l-a-n-g-a-n
um
the cognitive theoretical model of the
universe we had him on it's ctmu
um
and yes yes yes yes yes
yes yes and so
so
all of us from around the world are
talking about what this human
singularity is
um and we're taking it from our state of
being it's channeling through our state
of being so less and less intellectual
and more and more just oriented around
like
our own
purified state of being as well as the
future presence of the vision and then
that coming through
um
but nobody in a sense has some sort of a
concrete picture um and that is actually
good because we don't want a concrete
picture we we want to we want it to be a
dynamical interplay of all of the
visionary ideas um
and i think it's also really important
here to mention that there's a
simultaneous trajectory that is
entangled with the human singularity
which is the tech singularity
and
um
we can
off the bat we can also say that it's in
an entangled state where it's both
non-dual there's no difference between
human and tech singularity and yet at
the same time we can create a duality
just to help us understand where we want
to polarize towards so we want to
polarize towards the human singularity
and away from like an oligarchical
monopolistic
uh treating human-like cattle
we want to move away from that
right
so so it's it's helpful to create a
dualism just to be able to
uh envision
what the highest best case scenario is
and what we're actually aware of we're
aware of the totalitarian oligarchical
uh treating human-ass cattle efforts and
were totally aware of
how
malevolent and yucky that is and were
and were very clearly shifting away from
that towards very clearly um what is
biomimicking
um like the
as mama nui who's a uh an indigenous
kogi elder said on our show also
we're we're shifting more towards the
living original vision of earth or love
which is it's biomimicry it really is
nature itself is a generative function
the universe is a generative function of
oneness and it's very clearly seen in
like our fungal networks and so humans
are just ancestors of fungal networks we
come from the exact same abiogenesis
cellular lineage
and so we are all one and it's without a
doubt um that's exactly what is in this
vision of our architectures for that
uh enlightened civilization shambhala no
limits nation across the planet etc
but in terms of we have no attachment to
the trajectory no attachment to how it
it manifests and no attachment to some
sort of a final picture because it's
it's in a perpetual state of flux and
dynamic creativity
impermanence is the only permanence and
yet at the same time it's clear that
this infinite formless
intelligence is also permanent
but it's also impermanent and it's
fascinating and once you get to sort of
these realizations this is what you
could say is like the end of the path
and to stop intellectually masturbating
and instead begin doing the work which
is justifying where you're coming from
and then you can actually feel the
difference in your state of being when
you're coming from a place that's empty
of self-interest and you're coming from
a place that is life-serving itself
yes yes yes yes yes
um
yes so i'm i'm
a hundred percent
with you and i love everything you said
i love the human singularity so so so
important
um
[Music]
so if we look at the re now we only have
like five more minutes because i have
another another meeting right after so
and then we can continue we can continue
we're just opening the door to this love
you so much you're so
you're such a sweetheart i i love you i
love you
so much
thank you
wow
[Music]
it's good to feel the love wow when you
say that i love you
like i got it
uh
wow this was really powerful
i got like a wave of
[Music]
yeah me too and i feel our
dream team coming together
yes
yes
yeah just relax
await
all of that because i also had some
similar stuff
when i was in l.a like before i came
here one of the main things that was
coming up for me was like
i'm such an island right now like it's
like you you like sort of grok what the
nature of reality is and then you just
start like disseminating it via content
but we're such islands
and so now it's time to bring the
islands together into a unified
visionary dream team that can move
mountains and build shambhala across
this planet
yeah i cannot top that unified visionary
dream team i cannot top that okay
so we can build shambalas come on
[Music]
i'm so excited for all the next
generations that will get to be birthed
in shambhalas
whoa
holy wow like all the other selves
coming through to birth in shambhala and
like to
to like look at sort of our history and
just be like wow we got through a lot of
separation and like
you know a lot of conditioning um
to be able to have what we have now um
have such abundance now
wow
and that's that's the game that the one
plays with itself is like how badly can
i forget
yes
and and then remember
yeah
yeah
and that's why earth is so popular
it's so fun
yes rated five stars on universes.com
[Laughter]
[Music]
beautiful wow
all right let's yeah let's wrap so that
you can so yeah we're gonna wrap and
what i want to talk together next time
is if we're looking at this reality
transparent operating system
what does it mean to do the work and
what is this dream team and what is the
because see let's say you got the os
it it it's deciphered okay
how do you broadcast
do you have to broadcast i don't know
i'm asking not right now to answer
so let's say the operating system is
because it's actually it is we just have
to reveal it it's already here we are
leaving it every moment okay
so we let's say we reveal it do we need
to broadcast it
um do we need to
um
make it available
and
what kind of work what is doing the work
mean what is the dream team mean
so i wanted i want to leave us with
questions no answers today next time
that's easy
you know it's like netflix okay you're
binging okay next time we'll talk about
that okay
uh
and i love you and i love you and thank
you for the this beautiful energy you're
really i mean i can feel the difference
because i have not known you before
august so i've only seen you in august
twice and now
and
i'm telling you it's working it's
working so
thank you for being who you are thank
you for
softening and loving even more thank you
yeah
love you
bye
bye
bye